Putin wants another seven years as Russia's leader.
That's according to waiters
who say their sources have told them
that he's decided to run in Russia's elections in March.
He's already the longest serving leader Russia has had
since Joseph Stalin,
who ruled the Soviet Union for 29 years.
But should any of this really be a surprise?
Newton was first elected as president in 2000.
After his second term ended in 2,008,
he served as prime minister
before becoming president again in 2012.
Previously, Russia's presidents could only serve two
consecutive four year terms,
but in 2020
Putin changed the law
to allow him to one for president in 2024 and 2030,
meaning he could be in charge until 2036.
He'll be 84 years old then.
Critics say this is
Putin's way of making himself president for life
and that Russia's elections are not free and fair.
Putin has banned his
opponents from running against him before,
and his most high profile political opponent,
Alexei Novoni,
has been sentenced to 30 years in prison.
The Kremlin says Putin has not officially announced
till one for another presidential term just yet.